all right so welcome to the second day
of the algorithms and uncertainty
bootcamp so this morning our first talk
is going to be by Sethi an hour from
technial and he's going to tell us about
competitive analysis of online hover
thanks thanks very much
I'll start with some basic very basic
stuff definitions and then and then move
on my my talk will come my two lectures
will concentrate on the use of linear
programming and as is methodology for or
designing online algorithms so feel free
to stop and ask questions at any any
point of time okay so we'll just a quick
quick review of sure everybody knows
what's what's an online algorithm it it
it's an algorithm that gets the input
and pieces each time the algorithm gets
a request has to respond to it there's
no going back
and and so how do we measure the
performance of such an algorithm well
for we for this we have the measure is
called competitive competitive factor
and we say that an algorithm is
alpha-alpha competitive if for every
request sequence the performance of the
online algorithm meaning the cost of the
of the online algorithm normalized by
the cost of an optimal algorithm which
knows the full request sequence in
advanced but still has to pay something
if this normalized cost
is upper bounded by alpha for every
request sequence then we say that the
algorithm is alpha competitive we can
also use the randomization but then
again the algorithm uses random bits but
we want the Eknath so now we're looking
at the expected performance for every
request sequence expectation is taken
over the random bits used by the
algorithm and we say that for a
randomized algorithm the algorithm is
alpha competitive if the ratio between
the expectation and the optimal cost is
at most is at most alpha and in the in
these talks I'm only going to assume
that we have that the adversary is
oblivious meaning that that the
adversary knows knows the the algorithm
but not the outcome of the random bits
okay let's start with the most basic
online problem called ski ski problem we
go on a ski vacation renting skis cost
cost one dollar per day buying them
costs B dollars I won't tell you what is
B and the the problem is that we don't
know how many days of vacation we're
going we're going to have so the
question is rent rent or buy this issue
comes up in lots of algorithmic
scenarios and the for a deterministic
algorithm the algorithm is is is very
simple we just rent for a certain number
of days and then and then and then we
buy now for how many days should we
should we rent
well the optimal choice so M is the
number of rental days the optimal choice
of M is of course B so if the number of
days
less than ski days is less than B then
we will be we will be doing the same as
the optimal solution if the number is
more than B then we have accumulated
enough credit to pay for both the rental
and the end buying the skis because
together that costs to B and we know
that any algorithm had to pay at least B
so the competitive factor of competitive
ratio here is 2 and this is actually
optimal ok linear programming I think we
all know we have a bunch of linear
inequalities or equalities a linear a
linear objective function min or max I'm
in the online setting as we will see
we're not going to to to solve an LP but
we will we will do it iteratively in the
first in the first hour I'll be talking
a lot about set cover so just a quick
just a quick reminder we have a universe
an element we have a family of subsets
s1 through sm i assume that every set
has some cost CI the goal in set cover
is to find to find a collection of
minimum cost of this of these subsets so
that it covers the whole the full the
full universe we can write this as an
integer integer linear program this is a
good good exercise if you're not
familiar with this this kind of
formulations so we have a variable X I
this is our indicator whether we pick
pick or not the I set for each element
we wanted to be covered so Sigma X I
over all the sets that contain it should
be at least one and we want to minimize
the sum Sigma CI X I so this is the
integer program we relax it by allowing
the X I values to get fractional values
between 0 & 1 now this means that the
sum of the frak for each element the sum
of the fractions of the sets containing
it should be at least should be at least
1 this is an LP which can be solved in
polynomial time okay how do we go from
track from a fractional solution to do
it to an integral so set cover is an
np-hard problem so how do we how do we
go from a fractional solution to turn to
an approximate integral solution one
classic technique which I'll also be
using in the online setting is
randomized rounding we can think of the
so we have the output is we solve the LP
we have an optimal fractional solution
and and now in rap in randomized
rounding we think of these fractions as
as probabilities and so we pick each
element with the corresponding set with
the corresponding with the corresponding
probability now in terms of expectation
of the solution this will give us
precisely where the fraction of the cost
of the fractional solution however this
is not enough for covering we can only
guarantee that each element is covered
with probability or is not covered with
probability at most 1 over E but this is
this is not enough so we need to amplify
this probability but by repeating the
experiment log and vlog and times or a
priori multiplying the probabilities by
a log and and this will guarantee that
we are going to cover each element with
very high very high probability and of
course the cost will go up by by a
factor of log in the classic algorithm
for for set cover is the greedy is the
greedy algorithm very natural algorithm
and says the following week we start
iterating until we have until we cover
all the elements at any point of time we
pick the set which minimizes the the
cost its cost divided by the number of
new elements which are added to the
cover so we can think of it where we're
looking for the set which has the
minimum average cost in terms of this
cover the residual coverage that it that
it offers there are many ways to analyze
this this algorithm let me show you one
let me show you one way through dual
fitting since since I'll be talking
about the dual of set cover and also
about about dual dual fitting so it's a
dual program of set cover well in
duality we have we have a dual variable
for every primal constraint so that
that's going to be y YJ for every four
for every for every element we want to
maximize the objective function is
maximizing the sum of the Y's and now
the constraint is that for every set si
this
some of the Y J's is at most the cost of
that of that set this is the packing
packing problem okay so now how do we
use the dual for analyzing the primal
algorithm so the primal algorithm is
combinatorial algorithm it doesn't know
anything about the LP of course it's
just simple greedy algorithm and so we
need a need we need a way of setting the
dual the dual variables in accordance
with what the primal the primal does so
something is wrong here whether whether
were the font but the idea is that every
every dual variable the value that it's
going to get is equal to the cut to the
cost of the set at the moment of the of
its coverage but so if if if we use a
certain set CI and use it to cover a
hundred elements then each of these
elements is going to be set the value of
CI CI divided by 100 so this way we're
going to recover the dual is going to
recover the precise cost of the primal
algorithm the value of the dual each
dual variable is equal to the marginal
cost of covering it what about
feasibility so let's see by we're going
to up obviously we're going to violate
feasibility because we're talking here
about an np-hard problem let's see let's
see what happens so let's look at a
certain set s and let's suppose it's
element were covered in the order a 1 e
2 up to up to e K this may have happened
in one shot of course but let's just see
realize this
we know that when element AI is covered
we could have picked the set s and at
that point of time there were at least K
minus I plus 1 uncovered elements right
so this gives us an upper bound on the
value of the dual variable Yei
so when we sum up over all the elements
in the set we get the harmonic serious
so the sum of the Y's is at most the
cost of the set s multiplied by the
harmonic number which is approximately
LAN LAN LAN K if the set as K K elements
so this proves that we prefer so so we
know that each dual constraint is is
violated by a logarithmic factor if we
divide everything by log factors we get
a feasible assignment for the dual
variables however the ratio between the
primal objective function and the dual
objective function is is going to be
logarithmic so note what what is the
road which is being played by the dual
problem by weak duality we know that the
the dual the dual always gives us the
lower back any dual feasible dual
solution provides a lower bound on any
primal solution in particular the
optimal the optimal solution so we using
the greedy algorithm the primal
algorithm we have defined a feasible
dual solution and since the ratio
between the two objective functions is
at most log this is also the
approximation factor
okay let's move to the online
primal-dual framework I'll start with
covering problems and let's start with
the ski problem let's go back to the to
the ski problem so what else can be said
about this ski problem I mean the two we
saw the simple two approximation trivial
to approximation we know that it's tight
however that's only true
deterministically let's talk about the
fraction or a fractional solution for
the ski for the ski problem so the first
step is formulating the problem as an LP
now
formulating the ski problem is an LP is
maybe not as natural as as formulating
set cover but it's actually very simple
so we have a variable X which is
indicator for buying or not buying this
skis and for every day of ski we have an
indicator zi which is renting or not not
renting we want to minimize B X plus so
this is the color this is the cost of
buying this skis plus Sigma Sigma Zi and
the constraint for each day is that it
is covered either by buying or by
renting so X plus CI
is bigger than one okay let's look at
the relaxation of this problem now we
allow the X X variable in this Z eyes to
be to be better to have values between 0
& 1 now what does that mean in the
online in the online setting what's
what's a fraction was a fractional
solution well we get a new every day we
get a new constraint we get the i'f
constraint
X plus Zi and we have to we have to
satisfy that constraint now yeah yeah
what do you see okay oh yeah that's
that's the number of days it's true this
is this is not known this is not known
in advance but pardon let's say this is
looking at the final it's a final LP
sure I mean we it's true we don't know
okay yeah okay in advance so the
constraints appear one one by one every
day we get new currents we get an a new
constraint of the form X plus Z I bigger
than equal to 1 and the require the the
online requirement is monotonicity which
means that we the interesting variable
is X because the is just for the Iife is
just for the I today means that X is a
monotone non-decreasing function we
cannot sell back one tenth of the
equipment to the to the store so access
to air can only can only grow it cannot
it cannot decrease okay so here's the
dual of the there's a dual of the of the
ski of the primal LP we have a we have
the dual variable Y I for every for
every day and we want to maximize Sigma
Sigma Y and they don't constrain tur
that for every day Y I so this is a
maximization problem so we have to upper
bound the variables or there or linear
constraints so for every day why I is at
most one and the sum of the Y's is at
most is it most be and there and these
the primal constraints appear one by one
okay what's the algorithm so the
algorithm is basic it's simple it's
based on multiplicative updates so
initially X is zero we don't own any
fraction of the of the solution as long
as we haven't bought all of the all of
the equipment we need to satisfy the
constraint so we set Z I to be 1 minus X
so now the constraint X plus Zi is
satisfied but since we have what we have
acquired some credit because we we're
going to do at least one day of ski so
we update X multiplicatively so this
this happens to be the multiplicative
update I'll I'll talk later on how we
were where does it come from now so
let's yeah
to do what oh and that sure yeah it just
helps a little bit the analysis this is
the only this is the only issue sure
sure
this is what what you're suggesting is
definitely better just simplifies the
analysis okay so we know that the primal
solution is feasible just by just by
design so so this we have let's see what
is the ratio so we know that eventually
the ratio between the primal and the
dual this is going to be our competitive
factor so let's see what is the ratio
between the increase in primal and the
increase in dual it's one plus one over
see this is this is just the add
algorithm to remind you the change in
dual is one remember we increase the
dual by one the change in primal well
it's B times Delta X plus Zi which turns
out to be 1 plus 1 over C so this is the
ratio between primal and dual what about
what about feasibility so what one
constraint is that Y is less than or
equal to 1 that satisfied by definition
what about the other constraint Sigma Y
I less than or equal to 2 B so we need
to prove that after B days we're going
to buy the equipment then we don't need
to increase the Y's any more and that
would prove the dual feasibility so
that's actually easy easy to show the
since we have here a linear the update
is done by a linear a linear function
the
the value of the X variable is
determined by by geometric sequence and
when we do the calculation we get that
this is this is the value of x after be
after B days so we need to make sure
that the C is less than or equal to one
plus one over B to the power of B and a
minus one and this goes to this goes to
e so we get to the competitive factor is
one plus one over C which goes to e over
e minus one as B as B grows so this is
our competitive this is our competitive
factor for the randomized for for sorry
for the fractional algorithm but what
what can we do with it with this
fractional algorithm so one way of
viewing it is that the fractional result
is a goal by itself and this is true in
many cases I'm not sure in there that
this is true in there in this in the
case of ski but in this case going going
from a fraction or a deterministic
fractional algorithm to a randomized
integral algorithm is very natural and
this is actually the path that we're
going to take in many of these problems
we will first generate a fractional
algorithm a deterministic one and then
we'll turn it into an integral integral
integral randomized algorithm now
unfortunately generating the fractional
algorithm for that we can develop
general techniques going from fractional
to integral randomized that's more
problem
specific in this special case of this
key problem it's easy to to get a
fraction to get a randomized algorithm
so look at the zero one interval X 1 X 2
X X 3 etc are the increments of of X so
this is the growth of X every day the
randomized algorithm is going to choose
a value D uniformly at random in the 0 1
and the 0 1 interval and that will
determine the day in which we will buy
in which we will buy the equipment and
so if for example if d falls in this sub
interval covered by X 3 then we will buy
the equipment on the third day so
clearly the probability of buying of
buying the equipment on the eighth day
is X I and the probability and it's not
hard to show that the probability of
renting it on the earth day is at most
zi so it turns out that in expectation
the the expected cost of the randomized
algorithm is the same as the determinant
is the same as the fractional algorithm
which means that we have a fractional
algorithm which has whose competitive
factor is e over e minus 1 this is just
there are other ways of obtaining of
obtaining this this result so this is a
very very easy way of this is I think
the simplest examples that they can
think of using this primal-dual
technique for online algorithms
let's go to let's go beyond the the ski
problem
so in this in the case of the ski
problem if you think of the of the
constraint matrix in the LP all the
entries are in 0 1 but with a very
special structure of course let's say
what what can we say about a general
matrix where the entries are 0 1 this is
exactly as an instance of the of the set
cover problem so let's talk about the
online set cover problem we have
elements we have the set system we have
the costs as before but in the online
setting the elements appear one by one
each time an element shows up we need to
we need to cover it and once we pick a
set it cannot be we cannot sell it back
to the store like the like in the case
same as as this ski equipment we cannot
unchoose we cannot unchoose this set and
we may I mean we can think of both both
both models are legitimate where we know
in advance the structure of the we know
the set system we just don't know which
elements are going to show up this is
one possibility and the other
possibility is when an element shows up
it tells us to which set it belongs the
algorithm that I'm going to show to to
show here works for both for both models
okay so remember this is the LP for for
the set cover problem so X X of s is the
indicator for set for set as we want to
minimize Sigma C s XS we want to cover
every every element the constraints now
appear as before one by one and we need
to satisfy a constraint upon arrival and
variables can only be can only be
increased here is the dual we've seen it
already so Y of e is the dual dual
variable and the sum of the Y YZ is at
most the cost of the set for each set s
and we want to maximize Sigma ye so
Sigma Y is going to be our lower bound
on for the optimal cost it will it plays
the role of opt okay I'll show you two
two algorithms one is a discrete one
which generalizes the multiplicative
update ideas from the ski problem and
also a continuous view of that of this
discrete algorithm okay so initially all
the X values are 0 when a new element
arrives we run the following loop until
it's covered so as long as Sigma X s of
the element of the sets which contained
that element as long as that sum is it
most one we increase Y in in every
iteration here of the of this while loop
as long as we increase Y e by 1 and we
do a multiplicative update over the X
variables and this multiplicative
Update is inversely proportional to the
cost of the set so we want so for
element II sets which which contain e
but are cheap we want the X that there X
value to go up relatively fast while
expensive set will increase at slower at
a slower rate the proof of the
competitive factor is very similar to
what we saw in there in the case of this
key problem we need to show primal
feasibility dual feasibility and force
bound the ratio between the primal
increase and the dual and the dual
increase ok primal feasibility is just
by design because this Y loop just goes
and just goes on until until we cover
there until we cover the element
what about ratio between primal and dual
so in every iteration of the of the
while of the while loop we increase ye
by one so the change in the dual
variable is one and we do multiplicative
update over the sets that contain Y so
what is Delta P well it's Sigma CF s the
cost of s multiplied by the change in X
of s which is equal to CF s multiplied
by the change in cost but for every for
every subset s and well CF s cancels out
and we get here
to two terms the sum of two terms Sigma
X of s and Sigma 1 over m well X of s we
know this is at most one because we're
not feasible yet that's why we're in
this loop so the first term is upper
bounded by 1 and the second term is also
upper bounded by one because we have at
most an M set so overall it's it's at
most two so the ratio between primal and
dual is it most
- what about feasibility well similarly
to what we had in the case of scheme we
have here a geometric forever every for
every X is the sum of a geometric for
geometric series so if we focus on one
set then X of s increases for every
increase of Y of P when he belongs to
the set s we start from the initial
value of x of s is 1 over m times the
cost and Q in the geometric sequence
is one plus one over C of s and if if we
run this for C of s times log M rounds
we get that X after these many rounds
these many iterations I mean iterations
of this while loop the value of x of s
is at least 1 and then we don't need
just just one second and then we don't
need to increase X X of s anymore and
note that each increase of X of s is
triggered by an increase in Y of a so
once X of s reaches 1 we don't need to
increase the Y's anymore yeah
do you do some kind of normalization
with CSS to be at least 1 or with what
what is the normalization for the cost
is CS I'm assuming it's at least one
yeah so so we so we get that there that
the dual constraint is is violated by at
most a factor of a factor of log M so so
the so again dividing to make the duals
the dual the dual solution feasible we
just divided by log M so we get a
fraction a fractional solution which is
feasible and the ratio between the
primal and the dual is 1 over Rho of 1
over log log M and actually this result
is is tight for a fractional for
fractional algorithm
yeah let me show you now a second
algorithm that they're continuous so
it's actually the continuous continuous
counterpart of the discrete of their
discrete algorithm so in the continuous
algorithm in the continuous algorithm we
guess the connection between the primal
and the dual dual variables I'll tell
you shortly how how we do that but this
the the the primal variable is
determined by an exponential exponential
function of the dual variables and this
happens to be if the the choice for the
for this for the set cover problem so
now the algorithm is continuous we start
increasing the variables Y of e at
constant rate and that determines the
value for every set s that determines
the value of x of s and this is done
after until we the constraint is
satisfied so wife is increased and it
since this is a monotone increasing
function at some point the the variable
Y of e is going to be sorry the element
is going to be fractionally covered the
proof of the competitive factor is again
similar to what what we've already seen
we just here we show that the ratio
between the derivatives is is is
logarithmic so what happens here is that
the primal and the dual are primal is
feasible by design those solution turns
out to be feasible
and the ratio between the primal and
dual increase is logarithmic so we get a
logarithmic a logarithmic competitive
competitive ratio and yeah so primal
feasibility is by design yeah now we
want to show what is the ratio between
the the primal and the dual increase so
will between the it's continuous process
so we look at the ratio between the
derivatives
well the dual is increasing in constant
rate so this the derivative is equal to
2/1 and what about the primal change
well we're using the fact that the rate
of it's an exponential function so the
rate of change is equal to the value of
the function and when we do the and when
we do the calculations we get that it's
at most logarithmic in M and again at
the final step we get the familiar
familiar expression where we sum up X of
s plus 1 over m and we bound separately
each of these terms the first term is
upper bounded by 1 because we don't have
because we don't have yet a feasible
solution and the second term is is also
upper bounded by 1 because we have at
most M M sets
so that's the ratio between Prime primal
and dual growth as for feet as for
feasibility we use the fact that X of s
is at most is it most one and from that
we infer that the sum of the Y's is at
most CFS so we get dual we get dual
feasibility what's the connection
between the two between the two
algorithms well we use the fact that one
over yeah we just use the fact that X of
s is upper bounded by is upper bounded
by one and so so we have this inequality
and atom and this implies this
inequality I
so what's the connection between the
discreet and and very continuous
algorithm well we use the fact that one
plus one over C is an exponent is a
approximately e to the power of 1 over 1
over C as long as C is not is not too
too too small the description of the
discreet algorithm is simpler but the
convey the analysis of the continuous
algorithm is I think a bit a bit more
it's a bit it's a bit it's a bit simpler
soon I will show you another way of
describing the the continuous the
continuous algorithm ok what about love
the multiplicative updates so suppose we
have a general covering problem so in a
covering problem we have so the primal
the primal objective function is Sigma C
I X I and the constraint matrix is non
is non-negative so we have non-negative
values in the constraint matrix so each
time we get a new constraint the teeth
constraint and the teeth step we have
Sigma AI X I bigger than or equal to BT
and we do a multiplicative update which
is equal to one plane in the general
case in the case of set cover it was 1
plus 1 over C here it's going to be 1
plus AI divided by CI AI is the
coefficient of x I in the new constraint
and C is the coefficient in the in the
objective function and Y is increased by
1 so look from the local perspective the
change in the primal cost is Sigma CI
Delta X
which is equal to Sigma AI X I but we
know that this is at most BT because bt
because the constraint is not at this
point is not yet satisfied and this is
exactly the change in the dual dual cost
so this is just to give some intuition
where the how how these values are are
determined
okay what about lower bound let's see a
very simple very simple lower bound
suppose our objective function is Sigma
XJ the first constraint I'm going to
give you is this the excise need to sum
up to at least one well we have to set
them somehow but one of these guys is at
least 1 over N right so let's call it X
1 second constraint will be X 2 up to xn
is at least one well one of these guys
has to be is at least 1 over N minus 1
let's call him X 2 and so on the last
constraint is X and bigger than or equal
to 1 and we have to set it to be at
least one off line could just set xn to
be equal to one and the others are set
to 0 so the opt is one we pay one over
and for x1 1 over N minus 1 for X 2 etc
we get the harmonic sequence so we pay
lon and so we can see that this
logarithmic competitive factor is
actually under unavoidable even in this
simple scenarios I'm talking about the
fractional solution
okay how do we go to randomized to a
randomized algorithm so for the for the
set online set cover problem I'm just
going to apply the good old randomized
rounding that you have seen earlier but
instead of applying it only once as you
do in the offline cakes I'm just going
to do it in increments so whenever I
increment X of s by some Delta then I
also pick it to my cover with this
probability of course I have to amplify
the probability by a logarithmic factor
by a factor of log n so that a high so
that I get coverage with high high
probability so the competitive factor
turns out to be log M this is the loss
in the fractional case multiplied by log
n which is the loss in when we do the
amplification of the randomized of the
randomized rounding this is almost tight
the lower bound for for the integral
version is log M log and divided by log
log factor and surprisingly this this
process can be D randomized online so we
can get this result also
deterministically and it's in the way
the way it's the way it's done it's we
take the we use the method of of
conditional probabilities and and apply
applied online and this way you get the
very deterministic about
okay let's see an example which or which
has a slightly different flavor so so
far we have tried the goal was to
minimize the cost of a cover now let's
let's look from the perspective of the
dual or a maximization problem so a
simple simple example is what's called
online virtual circuit route we're
routing we have we have a graph we have
capacities on the edges we get requests
each request is specified by a sort and
a sink and we want to connect si tu ti
by a path in the network we have
remember we have capacities and we can
also reject the request and then lose
the profit and so we send for every
request we send one unit and this is our
this is our gain and we cannot do
rerouting okay so this is our LP we want
to maximize the sum of so RI P this is
the variable of the I request and this
is the amount of flow that we send on
path P which connects si si and Ti and
so now this can this is an LP so this
can be a fractional fractional value and
this this the sum for every request of
the fractional flow is upper bounded by
is upper bounded by one and for every
edge II the amount of flow that can go
fractional flow that can go through it
is it most its capacity you
okay the dual the dual packing problem
is sorry this is let's let's stick with
dual is the maximization problem and the
primal problem is the min is the
minimization problem so the the the
primal in this case well we have a
variable x e for every effort for this
constraint and so we want to minimize
sigma u e XE plus sigma z of RI which is
the constraint corresponding it which is
the variable corresponding to to this
constraint and for every path we need to
cover it so there are two ways of
covering it we have a global variable XE
which would work for all requests so
sigma x ii + z + zr zr i which is
specific for h for each request and now
here we have the the columns appearing
appearing one by one and again we have a
monotonicity requirement we cannot
decrease the flow on any on any path so
here is the so here's the primal dual
the primal dual algorithm so as as long
as we have a path whose so remember the
dual cont
in the primal constraint specifies that
the length of every path is at least one
whether it comes from X or from Z so if
the length so if I get now a particular
request if the length of every path is
at least one with respect to the X
variables then there I've already
satisfied from the perspective of the
primal of
thing is fine and I'm not going to send
any flow for that request I don't need
it for my primal-dual algorithm of
course in practice we will okay if you
don't have enough if you don't have
enough money from the X variables yeah
then you use the Z then you use the V Z
variable and as you can see if there is
a path if there is a path whose x length
is that most is it most one then then
you set Z to be equal to one there is no
need to be more precise more precise
than that and then you update
multiplicatively the X variables along
the path so now note our online
algorithm is not generating a fractional
solution it's generating right away an
integral solution either we send and so
and Y is said to be equal to what so
either we send one unit of flow on this
path wait whose X length is strictly
less than one or we don't send any any
flow so we get an integral for the flow
solution we get an integral we get an
integral solution let's see the analysis
the primal is feasible again by design
either the XS sorry oh yeah sure
that bandit on all the edges I mean this
is here I'm looking at this um so I'm
looking if the if there is a path whose
X length is strictly less than one then
I can pick any of these paths I don't
care which one and I'll send one unit to
flow on that path this is exactly what's
written here Sigma overall II and P it's
a path in the path it's a it's a it's a
it's a path so yeah so the primal
solution this Weaver is feasible the
length is at least one either through
the X variables or or with help from the
Z variable we can see that in a we'll
see that in every iteration the change
between P and the primal and the dual is
at most three the dual is going to be
we're going to violate capacities but
we'll bound well bound the violation so
so primal as I said is feasible by by
design the ratio between the primal and
the dual it's going to be duh it's
proved similarly to the previous
previous example and this can be shown
to be at most at most three again we use
the fact that the sum of the egg the
path that we chose the sum of the X is
is a
most is at most 1 as for the dual
feasibility well again we have the sum
of the flows is determined by a
geometric geometric sorry the xxe is the
sum of a geometric sequence and we know
that once x e hits 1 any path containing
that edge it has length 1 so we're not
going to push any flow on on that so the
question is how fast does X C reach 1
and when we do the calculation it takes
at most you of e times log n iterations
so this is the maximum amount of flow on
edge on edge e so we violate the
capacity by at most logarithmic at most
a logarithmic factor so we get here a
three competitive algorithm which
violates capacities by at most a factor
of log of log n we can change the
algorithm by a little bit we still have
multiplicative up updates but a slightly
different update update function and
that result in an algorithm which does
not violate cap at which does not
violate capacity constraint and with
this expression tells us what is the
what is the competitive factor and it's
a function of the minimum capacity and
if this minimum capacity is at least
logarithmic then we get that the
algorithm is log and
competitive we're not without violating
capacity constraint this result was
obtained earlier by Azara verboten
Plotkin how much more time do I have for
I'll try to wrap up the first half so so
far what what we have seen is we have
either rose in a car appearing in a
covering LP or columns in in in a
packing LP primal variables are updated
our updated multiplicatively the dual
variables are updated updated in an
additive in an additive way all the the
proofs had the following structure we
show primal feasibility we show duel
either feasibility or almost feasibility
and we also bound the ratio between the
primal change and and the dew and the
dual change sometimes since the solution
is only nearly feasible then this nearly
goes into the competitive competitive
factor going so this is for the
fractional solution going for the
integral for an integral solution then
this is a more sometimes randomized
rounding works in general this is a more
ad hoc
process so that is that looking at at
online problems from from this
perspective gives you a more principled
way of designing designing an online
algorithm and you don't you can replace
in many cases you can replace a
potential function by the dual or the
primal objective function depending from
which perspective you're working and
that and that gives you the base some
the basis of reference with respect to
which you do your competitive analysis
the other advantage is that since we're
working with an LP the competitiveness
is proved with respect to a fractional
solution and which sometimes has its
advantages I guess I'll I'll stop for
for a break at this point okay thanks
so just a quick comment so you always
say that the multiplicative updates but
what that it's a multiplicative update
in the primal but it's not true most men
typically and additive right they go
together through beginner but I think
the point is actually that we want to
work together with both primal and dual
dual there and then you're right we have
to we have to do both
in a minute I mean net in the next talk
I'll I'll I'll show another way of
viewing it which might be more natural
might be a partially answering your your
your cut your comment some more
questions
let's take